so on the mound for the yankees is going
to be that young man domingo hermann
let's do it in the bronx first pitch
swung on in sky to left field frazier's
there
frazier makes the play one pitch one out
tony kemp
three homer 16 rbis
hits this one well to right judge going
back judge turning around and that
baby's gone
i am thoroughly impressed with tony kemp
we're seeing him you know as as an a for
the first time but how he handles inside
pitches
the o2
swing and a miss moorland down on
strikes
but the a strike first with the kemp
home run it's open one and the new york
yankees coming about and this yankee
lineup is going to face this
right-hander
wine toward right but brown is there so
that's out number
against one very hard but into the glove
of a diving tony kemp who is playing
with the shift on right up the middle
and kemp made a sensational play make
your presence felt
had some weird action to it too well not
only is it tailing away he stayed inside
the ball so it's tailing
but he also this ball is really taking a
dive that was seeing the ball well on
both sides
strike three calls so bassett got the
call there sanchez can't believe it so
sean barber
to be honest an interesting strike zone
in the very first inning hayes lead won
nothing
swinging a miss nasty pitch
vermont has struck out three in a row
swing and a miss so her mom brings up
three strikeouts in the inning no run to
him no errors in one man left on base
let's go to the bottom of the second in
the bronx it's one nothing athletics
yankees are
waiting
before the call is made by barber they
want to make sure i think that's what
really set gary off as stanton just
waited and waited it put you in a
position where that ball up and in is no
fun
lace to right field it's a base hit in
front of brown
yankees first and second nobody out here
in the second
1-1
broken back ground ball
bob will throw the first just throw the
second just in time and on the first
it's a double play
what was urchela doing
i think he actually got splinters from
the bat in his eye i think he might have
got something in his eye from the bat
incredibly unfortunate certainly not a
double playground ball he hit it so
softly but you can see he's in pain
right there
and does start to jog to first base but
he doesn't know where the ball is
but that's where you go back to relying
on
line drive and a base hit to left field
relying on your veteran approach as
you're just
runner goes sanchez's throw is not in
time
andrew's dancing off of third
grounded to first fair ball
great play by lemayo as
andrew stays put it there
[Applause]
fly ball left field on the run toward
the line in the corner is frazier will
make the play
and that'll do it
chapman hits one high and deep left
center field gardner to the wall and
that baby is gone
chapman takes on the deepest part of the
ballpark at yankee stadium that would be
left center field
and the a's lead to nothing
you start fouling off pitches you
recovering and
you know it escalates but you know
that's to me the way to get out of these
things you know you stay inside a little
bit
the one two
and that one gets past murphy and goes
to the backstop allowing judge to go to
second
and he worked another walk so first and
second for the yankees one man out and
that brings up torres
line drive base hit center field
judge rounding third he will score going
to third a stand the throw is
not in time and dropped by chapman it's
an rbi single for urshela hickey's on
the board two to one
[Applause]
swag and a miss nasty pitch by bassett
so the yankees get one it's a two one
easily freeway in my opinion when you're
comparing the two that's
i think a beauty there for elvis andrews
as he punches it into right field for a
base hit
there's a shot base hit center field
he's bouncing right back two on nobody
out
and it's high walk them the bases are
loaded for olsen nobody out
olson
base hit left center field that's gonna
bring home a pair
kept racing around second he's gonna go
to third and it's four to one the a's
lead olson comes through
so matt olson i guess that would fall
under the category of not trying to do
too much
and it's four to one that's it for
herman it's all pitching change and
still nobody out
by barber
and cortez gets the strikeout that's a
big strikeout
another strikeout as chapman goes down
fly ball
right center
gardner makes the play and that's a big
league performance by next to cortez
first and third nobody out he does not
let a run score
one-two
that one has driven to left field pinder
back still back this is still back and
he's gonna play it off the wall
frazier with a leadoff double he missed
a home run by about about a foot put in
half
the o2 swing and a miss yankees waste
the lead off double strikeout ground
ball a third strikeout and bassett does
the job no runs a hit one man left will
go to the sixth inning it's 4-1 open
now to the bottom of the six yankees in
need of a rally rally they trail four to
one here's gary sanchez
that one's drilled to left field fair
ball it is gone it is god see ya a home
run sanchez it's four two ways
again i mean everything perfect little
movement and just straight to the
baseball and when he does that i mean
his talent and his strength and his
ability to drive the ball that is what
is is good in the game when gary sanchez
has got it together
they're playing their best baseball
lined and passed to diving chapman two
really good at bats for frasier as the
ball goes to the wall and frazier with
another lead-off double he had one in
the fifth and now one here in the
seventh
4-2 oakland
2-1
base hit that'll score frazier a bullet
up the middle by judge
and it's now 4-3 athletics
well they'll go to the bullpen it'll be
petite against stanton yankees have the
tying run
not
second punch down and a base hit pass
the diving olson
judge rounds third he'll score
a big rbi single for stanton and the
yankees have tied the game at four
he could not hold up so murphy goes down
on strikes
what a performance by chad green he gets
pinder looking and he strikes out the
side we go to the bottom of the eighth
it's four four
and geo orchella will lead off
driven to center field
hannah back still back track wall weak
see ya yankees lead 5-4
a home run into monument park
for urshela and the yankees have come
all the way back to take the lead
99 miles an hour paul on the way in and
104 on the way out
reversal 104 that'll even go dead center
field
and gideon's a pinch hit walk the 90s
they're they're sinker and they're four
seamers it's basically the same velocity
line droid drive bases to left field
two runs will score a huge hit for dj
lemayo and the yankees now lead seven to
four and they turn to araldis chapman to
get it done
and he walked him
karen boone is somewhat fired up and
there he goes oh you saw that coming
there he goes
and to no avail as it's grounded to
second the throw to chapman is dropped
and the a's are still alive
and chapman deals
ground ball bases to right field
kind of scores
olson moves to second it's an rbi single
for l'oreal and now the game comes down
to chapman against chapman
swinney
[Music]
103 miles an hour
chapman nails it down and the yankees
get a gritty gutty comeback victory a
big league victory and are sheller with
a big home run and if the yankees have
a highlight video at the end of the year
you can name it it don't come easy